Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at whether
the United States president has to report
food, transportation and other such gifts
from taxpayers on his or her taxes.
Ever wonder if the president has to report
food, transportation and other such gifts
from taxpayers on his or her taxes?
Well, wonder no more.
The short answer is- no.
And although it's difficult to find an official
explanation (or even a detailed one), after
doing a deep dive into U.S tax law, the answer
appears to lie in the United States' ridiculously
complicated tax code.
To begin with, we’ll look at the matter
of Gifts
The transportation, security, housing and
other benefits received by the President and
his family are not considered gifts.
But assuming they were, neither Barack nor
Michelle would have to pay any tax imposed.
Under U.S. Income Tax law, in particular 26
USC § 102(a), gifts are, with some exceptions,
specifically excluded from taxable income:
“Gross income does not include the value
of property acquired by gift, bequest, devise,
or inheritance.”
Rather, taxes owed for any gift are governed
by U.S. Estate and Gift Tax law, specifically
26 USC § 2502(c) which imposes the burden
of paying any taxes due on the person who
made the gift:
“The tax imposed by section 2501 shall be
paid by the donor.”
This gift tax will kick in once the yearly
value of any gift exceeds the annual exclusion
rate per person (currently $14,000) or once
the total amount of gifts given over a lifetime
exceeds the lifetime exemption for both gifts
and transfers on death ($5.4 million).
So, if the perks of Air Force One and the
White House were considered gifts, the U.S.
citizens would owe the IRS some dough on these
"gifts" to the President.
Which, of course, is absurd.
But, luckily, these extras are not simply
the largess of the people, but rather, are
necessary for the President to do his job.
As such, according to federal tax law and
regulations, the gratis transportation, food
and housing received by the Commander-in-Chief
are non-taxable fringe benefits.
(Note: at one time the President actually
had to pay for all this type of stuff himself,
including any White House expenses, which
is partially how Thomas Jefferson became so
hugely in debt.
This was also a financial burden on rare non-independently
wealthy Presidents before the law was changed,
such as James Garfield who had previously
been a janitor, carpenter, and a school teacher,
among other things.
When he was President, he didn't even have
enough money to own a coach and had to borrow
one to get around.)
Now we move on to Non-Taxable Fringe Benefits
Defined by the IRS as "a form of pay for the
performance of services," fringe benefits
are often taxable as income to the employee
who receives them.
However, there are certain perks that are
specifically excluded from the imposition
of income tax, for regular Joe's and the President
alike:
First, Meals and Lodging
Although we were unable to find support for
this proposition, it appears that this exclusion
(26 USC § 119) would apply to the keep the
White House, its staff (including a private
chef) and certain meals out of the First Family's
taxable income.
It provides in pertinent part:
“There shall be excluded from gross income
of an employee the value of any meals or lodging
furnished to him, his spouse, or any of his
dependents by or on behalf of his employer
for the convenience of the employer, but only
if – (1) meals are furnished on the business
premises of the employer, [and] (2) the employee
is required to accept such lodging on the
business premises as a condition of his employment.”
In the case of the President, this also applies
to vacation homes and travel.
As historian Richard Norton Smith said:
“If the president goes on vacation, it's
part of the job, because the president never
goes on vacation.
I don't think you can legitimately argue against
the communications and everything else that
travels with and surrounds a president.”
That said, the President and his family are
responsible for paying for certain items,
including "all their own groceries, drinks,
dry cleaning and even their toothpaste."
Although as one commentator wryly put it:
"the private chef then prepares dinner using
those groceries."
Now to Transportation and Security
When it comes to excluding Air Force One,
the Presidential limousine and all of the
security for the president and family, Treasury
Regulation 1.132-5 in pertinent part notes
that
“the government employee may exclude the
value of the personal use of the employer-provided
vehicle that the security study deter-mines
to be reasonable and necessary for local transportation.
Similarly, if an employee travels on a personal
trip in an employer-provided aircraft… the
employee may exclude… the value of the flight…”
It further notes that:
“Income does not include the value of a
working condition fringe [which is] any property
or service provided to an employee . . . to
the extent that, if the employee paid for
the property or service, the amount paid would
be allowable as a deduction . . .”
This certainly appears to be the case, as
each of these expenses would be incurred as
a result of the president’s employment.
Bonus Fact
• All federal employees, including the President,
are prohibited from keeping gifts from foreign
governments and officials that are worth more
than $350.
However, particularly with lavish, ceremonial
gifts given by other heads of state to the
President, the gifts are typically graciously
accepted, then turned over to the National
Archives.
For domestic gifts, as legislative attorney
Jack Maskell notes "President is generally
free to accept unsolicited personal gifts
from the American public . . . from relatives
and gifts that are given on the basis of personal
friendship."
However, the president must "publicly disclose
personal financial information, including
personal gifts over minimal amounts ($350
as of 2012)."